or Sudan's paramilitary rapid support
forces say it's taking control of the
police headquarters in Khartoum this
video appears to show Fighters at the
site heavy shelling and airstrikes have
been carried out across the city as
fighting between the Army and its rival
paramilitary Force enters its 11th week
more than 2 000 people have been killed
and about one and a half million forced
to leave their homes Emma Morgan has
more from omdaman near Khartoum
the headquarters of the central Reserve
police a militarized unit of the police
force has been the scene of intense
fighting between the central Reserve
police and the paramilitary rapid
support forces for the past three days
now the rsf on Sunday announced that
they have gained full control of the
headquarters and it lies in close
proximity to another camp that belongs
to the rsf also in the southern part of
the capital sources in the Army and few
residents remaining in the southern
parts of the capital tell Al Jazeera
that fighting is still ongoing and that
the Sudanese Army fighter jets and more
troops to reinforce their presence and
continue attacks on the rsf around the
central Reserve Police Headquarters now
that's not the only place where there's
been fighting between the two sides
there's been artillery strikes launched
from the city of andhurman towards the
northern part of the capital and air
strikes launched on rsf positions also
in the Northern parts of the capital
there's also been fighting in Nyala in
South indar for residents say that
several homes were hit as a result of
fighting between the paramilitary rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army in
South Darfur this all happens with no
sign of talks ongoing between the rsf
and the Sudanese Army the mediators
Saudi Arabia and the United States who
are facilitating talks between the two
in the Saudi city of Jeddah announced
that talks have been adjourned and it's
not clear when they will resume again
meanwhile civilians continue to be
caught in the crossfire between the rsf
and the Sudanese Army and many
especially in the southern parts of the
capital at the moment say that they
don't know how they can escape the
fighting hippo Morgan Al Jazeera on
durman